things yeah I mean we we've kind of
sorta mapped out the best really more or
less oh yeah there's like a few weird
things you've got in the jungle weird
bugs like where's not yet Vietnam has
some surprises for us here with fangs Oh
you ever seen those oh the Sulawesi
bores or though that deed here really
vampire deer I don't know I don't know
about vampires it's the craziest looking
thing ever it's deer with fangs like
crocodile looking fangs that come
hanging down like this this is some
Jackalope thing oh god it's a weird
little animal it's not a big deer either
well do you know look at that thing
vampire deer that's a real animal look
at that how [ __ ] strange what was this
what was in this coffee Jamie look at
that thing look at the [ __ ] teeth on
that thing it's probably something akin
to their antlers they easy to defend
themselves okay that's not real it's not
real because that's a mule deer see that
one that you just picked that's that's
some Photoshop [ __ ] what's
interesting is apparently
elk have these things called the people
call them ivories now but they what they
are is at one point in time they had
tusks yeah like a boar yeah like giant
tusks that probably aided them and their
fights and they eventually shrank and
now they're just this weird sort of
nubby thing I actually have some here
I'll show it to you yeah yeah they're in
the after the podcast I'll show em to
you but they there are this weird thing
that's like not quite a tooth it's ivory
it grows inside their head and at one
point time it was some kind of a weapon
just like their head is I mean the
antlers are you know that's the largest
but how do we describe this what was the
quickest growing thing in the animal
world is the the antlers of an elk okay
look how [ __ ] huge they are they fall
off every year and they grow back every
year and it's all just for fighting and
they used to grow back tusks too well
these two have to the answer the tusks
were permanent but they used to just
it's just for duking it out yeah it's
crazy weapon their sexual selection well
you want to know really weird thing of
the dung beetle
there's a conserved system whereby in
some dung beetles the amount of weaponry
you have is your antler is inversely
proportional to the amount of copulatory
apparatus you have where it counts well
and so if you have really impressive
weaponry you're not able to do quite as
much and that may be the engine of
speciation is because the vagina and
penis in that system is a lock-and-key
and so if something shrinks too much
then you can't necessarily get get the
job so if a greedy dung beetle with
giant horns just [ __ ] everybody up his
genes can't pass on maybe there's a
certain amount of cooperation that's
needed in the dung beetle world yeah
can't have an oppressor
kennefa Genghis Khan of the dung beetle
world the patriarchy and the dung beetle
world look at the size of the antler on
that guy yeah what girls make fun of
them probably the dung beetle world like
the guy with the Lamborghini exactly
like what's he doing over there with
these giant it looks like elk antler's
probably it's a tiny little dick you
want you want a guy who's just got a
little like that like that guy probably
probably hung like a roach right